so the goal of my research team is to
push forward fundamental NLP
technologies so most of the students
they work on fundamental NLP problems
such as parsing and also information
extraction problems to extract
structured information from unstructured
text to make algorithms intelligent in
understanding human languages in
generating human languages across
domains
what's more fundamental we're trying to
train algorithms that can learn and that
can generalize from a more a cognitive
point of view a real NLP system is an
NLP system that can really understand
what you say know someone's opinion me
contradict yours what my friend Alan
it's all about your perspective who are
we if what is the nature of this reality
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Alan Saucon we are on-site
at the beautiful Westlake University in
Hangzhou China we are now going to be
talking about natural language
processing NLP we have dr. you a Jung
joining us on the show highway hi Alan
thank you so much for coming on the show
that's my onna it's such a pleasure for
us as well thank you for those that
don't know us background he's an
associate professor NPI
at Westlake University focused on
machine learning based natural language
processing web information extraction in
financial market prediction in NLP he
works on fundamental problems such as
parsing and generation in particular for
English and Chinese and you can find his
links in the bio below
all right way let's start things off
with one of our favorite questions we
like asking our guests what are your
thoughts on the direction of our world I
mean this is a complex question I think
we're moving very technological and the
trend will not stop I think we'll grow
more and more technological but in terms
of whether this is a correct direction
it's debatable I think I mean this might
be a philosophical question but which we
can discuss a little bit later we've had
so many conversations on our show about
the direction of our world advancing
technologically and calling it a wisdom
race that as the exponential
technologies become democratized that
the power of causing malevolence becomes
democratized catastrophic malevolence
and our wisdom has to increase our
consciousness has to rise up fast our
awareness must rise up fast and that
awakening process can be catalyzed also
through technology and so it's this
process of being able to figure out hmm
how do we awaken fast enough to be able
to deal with the godlike power that
we're I'm mocking yeah I'm a big big fan
of that one what would you say is a key
maybe skill or essential that we can
embody to make sure that we win that
wisdom race first of all I don't
completely agree that we're we're
necessarily in that wisdom race but in
terms of we need to be more
technological in order to survive in the
current society and this is true there
are a lot of interesting things to
discover and there are a lot of
and changes that we need to adapt to I
think well in order to better survive at
least we need to ensure that we have the
necessary education and I think that's
the most important thing and maybe we
need to be creative because with every
technological advance on the way people
work change so for example with machines
they replace manual tools a lot of works
they change and nowadays when artificial
intelligence comes into play maybe more
manual jobs will be replaced and people
have to move to like more creative jobs
I think that's that that's the trend
yeah yeah but as I said I don't
necessarily this trend because the way
life should be is very debatable from
the philosophical point of view why do
you not think we're in a wisdom race
well I think we are but we're made
passively because after like because we
exist in this society and it's moving
technologically and we have to we have
to participate in the race right but
this is not necessary what like people
subconsciously are willing to for
example a lot of technologies are
created to make your life easier but in
fact everyone feels that the life has
becoming more and more difficult because
you have to acquire more knowledge in
order to adapt to the new ways of living
versus maybe some of the more primordial
ways of living which are still somewhat
present and some of the less developed
places on the planet where that's all
right where you're just kind of like
just chilling during the day yeah you
know get some water get some food yeah
they may just show yeah yeah yeah
so it's debatable whether or not being
pushed into the economic machinery of
cities is actually a higher quality or a
higher standard of happiness and
flourishing yeah that's what I meant
that's what you need no oh that's it
maybe that's different from a lot of
people that are really they're going to
unpack I think the statistics are
somewhere in the ballpark of up maybe
eight to eight out of every ten people
are living within sixty or so miles of a
100 kilometers or so of a coast yeah and
those are mostly cities big cities yeah
over 50% of people living in big
metropolis with economic machinery
that's buzzing every single day yeah
they are hectic every day yeah the email
boxes in the in the text boxes down the
WeChat Jets and they're all filled in
you got a reply in your tasks switch all
the time and you know and you have to
earn the money so that you can pay for
the rent and pay for the food yeah yeah
and this is the way we're live right now
yeah we may we may need to okay will
full circle back to this exact topic at
the end let's get into the journey yep
who are you growing up and how did you
get interested in computer science right
so I got interested in computer science
because I had a chance to like play the
computers when I was a kid and at that
time I thought okay computers are
intelligent because I can play games and
the computers can tell me like 6 plus 5
is 11 right so that makes me feel very
interested in learning algorithms so as
I grew up I started to learn the
mathematics and data structure etc
are behind computer science and I start
to be able to hack some of the games and
I become like more and more attached to
computer science and I chose that as a
major when I went to college you know
continue this line of work
cool cool those are always really
powerful moments when you first of all
computers are just like a massive hack
for humans to process information and I
mean like wow what a crazy advancement
computers have been in the last century
okay and then it's always really
powerful when then you are able to
adjust a variable in the simple click
computer game that is then literally
immediately has an effect on the game
yeah and you're like oh exactly for
example you can lock a part of the
memory and figure out where it is you're
a health point and you can lock that
part of the minute and it can play home
forever
oh yeah and not take damage things like
that or you can like lock your money to
be infinite yeah yeah buy whatever you
want yeah yeah in a strategy game of
course okay and that was at Tsinghua
University where that was the the
undergraduate for computer science and
then you made this big leap to Oxford
for your masters and for your PhD and
let's talk about what it was like first
to get into set to school machine
translation this is from Chinese to
English but also the immersion into the
United Kingdom all right and into just
English culture versus Chinese culture
what was that like the cultural
difference because I went from China to
the UK in 2050 a 2005 at that time the
difference between China and the UK was
relatively large I believe because China
was relatively less developed so I went
to the UK I felt everything was
expensive at that time and my English
was not that good as well and people my
classmates call my English English
because I was from Beijing and I used to
say her all the time and some of them
say this is pirate English yeah like
this but the sort of icon adapted to the
to the English environment and it's like
my broken Chinese is so bad right now
people can't understand me at all even
the machines that I tried to translate
to can't understand my Chinese it's so
bad well I just when we worry in the
fre-chan I just mentioned the four
characters I think I think you can speak
that well at least I can understand it
but anyway so in terms of Education so
one of the sharp differences I found was
that in Oxford when I took a course and
I'm gonna submit my exercises and every
time I got a correct mark a tick but
this was very different from Chinua
because in Chinua and when I was in a
high school so every time I said me
something is I very easily get across so
which is incorrect so I felt that the
education was very encouraging so there
are no very strict room of simple
difference like having an X for an
incorrect versus having a check mark for
a correct right you saw a greater amount
of like encouragement from a process
that was like kind of like rewarding the
proper answers I believe at least I
found that I found that the marking was
very encouraging because there are a lot
of ways you can understand on you can
answer a question and most of the time I
got a correct mark and I was encouraged
and I gained a lot of confidence in my
learning actually when I was in Oxford
I chose seven courses and I got an A+
for all of them and that was a later on
the people say that was remarkable in
Oxford us nobody seemed to have done
that
but a twist in the story and later when
I became a teaching assistant I realized
oh it's not so difficult to give correct
marks to every question it's actually
easier to give correct mark so every
question then to find out a particular
error from the student marking sheet so
I think part of the encouraging marking
scheme may result from the reluctance
from the TA to spend too much time on
student marking Wow I mean that's that's
ironic right yeah so then what formula
is actually optimal for education than
for marking and for kura or helping with
the closely feedback for a student to
learn I mean to my personally I believe
that a more encouraging way you're
marked the answer sheet is necessary but
I mean maybe the the Chinese system the
teaching assistants were more serious
than in the UK system and then what
about the immersion to statistical
machine translation from Chinese to
English and teach us about how you got
interested in that and what those first
days were like right right so I chose
natural image processing also because
I'm so interested in machine
intelligence because at the time I were
to choose a supervisor in Oxford there
were quite a few alternatives and some
like professors they also worked on
software engineering and other topics so
but after I took the course and I
learned about natural metal processing I
thought this is really interesting and
like just a few months after I developed
my first system that can parse Chinese I
was so proud because I saw in the
monitor that my system can intelligently
analyze the structure of Chinese
sentences I thought this is amazing
again so I went into this field and you
know so at the time I started working on
natural language
the thing it's not a very popular field
so when I mentioned the word and now
people will not know it people will feel
okay this might be something like a
psychology therapy or something it's
very different from nowadays there's
also the neuro linguistic programming
which is another tactic that people use
in like motivation or an actualization
or persuasion and they're all the type
of stuff so this is the other NLP which
is natural language processing all right
yeah yeah yeah okay and then it's also
very interesting thinking about when you
first figure out how to parse a sentence
I mean the whole idea that we found a
way to vibrate our vocal cords to create
meaning for another creature to
understand and then share knowledge
through that process and then figure out
words which then make it easier words
are like a compression algorithm for
communicating in the reality that we're
in and so then now you're like okay well
let's label the natural language that
we've created and let's parse it for
meaning for okay so you have to parse it
for both syntax and semantics so meaning
is semantics and syntax is the order of
nouns and verbs the structure I was like
this opposed yeah so you have to do that
for Chinese which is like way different
than English alright so the underlying
technology are similar because when I
started to do research people have
created those linguistically annotated
corpus like the corpora the expert will
basically manually mark what are the
sentence structures for both English and
Chinese and then what's left for the
algorithm to do is learn from those
manual labels the regularities or the
pattern
or the statistics and after they learn
from human annotation they can try to
mimic human annotation when they like
when a New Testament is is given so the
the algorithm will basically just use
statistical information to do the
prediction of unseen cases and that
helps me to use similar algorithms to
deal with English and Chinese and I
don't have to be a deep linguistic
expert to be able to develop those
algorithms and that's a good thing but
for Chinese language processing there
are also unique problems to solve for
example word segmentation
because Chinese sentences are written as
continuous sequences of characters
without word eliminators this is quite
unlike English so unique problems
whether you can segment a sentence into
words before more like a natural
language processing tasks can be
performed
would that be that English has words
like love and - yes in Chinese the
Chinese has function words as well but
like every word is written continuously
just imagine you have an English
sentence with without spaces and Chinese
sentences are written like that damn
without spaces until the period under
the pyramid yeah whoa
okay interesting already such a
fascinating difference between the two
languages
okay so then
that would be like us having to figure
out where the word ends and where the
next word starts so then it could be
that three characters equal a word you
are only two of the characters equal of
water that's correct
yeah gosh
or just one character is the word and
the next characters are at the beginning
of the new word yeah or maybe ten
characters could be a very long word but
that's rare what's the longest word so
the longest word in some of the corpora
are between ten and twenty characters
and those are idioms I think yeah or
transliterated terms there are long
names after transliteration it becomes a
lot of characters okay so let's come to
this to this this on this this this
parsing analysis so we we have something
like a a a need to understand both the
syntax and the semantics so how does
that work
like okay let's start with this is this
a reinforcement machine learning process
no so for parsing so if you have manual
labels for every constituent in a
constituent tree or for every
independence in relation in a dependency
tree then you could have supervision
signal over every decision so you don't
have to do reinforcement learning but
like your question is also interesting
because there have been
attempt to learn the syntactic structure
from unlabeled data and when that
happens technique such as reinforcement
learning can be useful at one point the
data was unlabeled and then we labeled
the data to Train
yeah machine a machine and then that's
reinforcement no that's not really horse
that was supervised learning it's
supervised yeah okay
so us labeling unstructured data is
supervised yep machine learning and the
reinforcement machine learning is when
we label the data the machine learns and
then it gives us another understanding
and then we keep correcting it or how
you write reinforcement learning is more
like learn by exploration so it's like
you ask the algorithm to explore the
possible structures by itself but a
certain stage you give it an award the
word function to tell it whether you are
like labeling is correct and this kind
of a word function might be external for
example you make the Machine parse a
sentence by itself and then asks ask it
to make some decisions such as
predicting the sentiment of a sentence
based on your parse tree so and then the
sentiment is human label so you give the
like parsing algorithm and external
reward so that the parsing algorithm
will come back and figure out okay maybe
this is not a correct syntax so it has
to change this ok ok ok got it
supervised machine learning is labeling
unstructured data feeding that into the
machine and reinforcement learning is
then assigning a reward function for the
machine to go towards so that if it does
succeed at picking with a certain amount
of confidence that this is this was the
noun or this was the the
the the most correct what we took from
the audio form and picked a word that
you've rewarded for and then it learns
that okay that was the word chair and
sort of yeah sort of you know this is
all really complicated yeah that's true
it's too technical to the specific field
it's very very technical especially when
there's differences between Chinese and
English I think that's so interesting
let's briefly mention along the way as
well um you built
Z par mm-hm so statistical
multi-language parser for English and
Chinese so when was that built and how
did that come up for you or I should be
used right so the par was the project
that I started off when I was a student
in Oxford so basically I was trying to
work on parsing for the languages and I
was not so satisfied with existing
libraries so I decided to develop my own
parsing library so my initial thought is
that I want to optimize every bit in my
software so that it runs fast it takes
the least memory and it's my own
framework so that I can develop novel
algorithms on that it all started with
that and I remember the first version of
step are started off with my first paper
on parsing and later as I went to
Cambridge to do my postdoc research and
after I went to Singapore to do my
alaikum to be a faculty I continued my
development of that par along the way
yeah so that was a an ongoing project
yeah and having been used by so many
people now around the world it's cool
seeing something that you make that
makes a really significant push for an
entire field to under
and and opie better I think one
uniqueness about that part is its
optimization and because it runs fast
they draw attention from like a lot of
people this kind of optimization are not
only from my software engineering
optimization but also from the
underlying algorithms because at the
time I was doing the research people
work on parsing they carefully designed
some like dynamic programming algorithms
to make sure that the search algorithm
can find a hi squirt parse tree that a
model can find and that causes a problem
which is a trade-off between efficiency
and accuracy because the more sources of
information you want to use for your
parser
the slower your parser will run due to
the use of dynamic program and instead I
try to develop an algorithm called
transition based algorithm so it allows
us to use whatever sources of
information we need
with linear runtime complexity and the
sacrifice is that the search algorithm
in in search algorithm the inference
algorithm is not optimal and I try to
solve the problem by designing machine
learning algorithms to guide search
algorithm so that the algorithm can run
both fast and accurate I think that was
the the success of Japan now the whole
field has transitioned from a
statistical machine learning driven
field into a deep neural network
learning driven field and at this time
transition based answers have become
maybe less popular relatively less
popular as it was maybe six years ago
but I still continuously work on
transition based parser and in this year
in a top conference there was one paper
from Berkeley confirming that a recent
putter
of our research group when combined with
large-scale pre-trained language model
still works the best like in the
benchmarks well that's a continuation of
this line of work
mm-hmm speed and accuracy are the big
ones yeah you know we when we speak into
voice to text we care a lot about speed
and accuracy yeah I'm great ones yeah
especially when you think about the
industry and people worried about the
speed of their systems because they have
so many requests from users yes yes yes
and then you mentioned that you went
onto this assistant professorship at
Singapore University of Technology and
design and that was for six years so
teach us about that period of time and
what it was like being a professor
starting to teach young people all right
so the thing about professor is that you
take more responsibility in organizing a
research group and you also do teaching
for the teaching part I love teaching
and part of the reason I want to be a
faculty is because I can teach I can
organize whatever the research field has
achieved into teaching materials and I
can impart that to students so that they
are equipped with the necessary tool kit
so I like the teaching part and I like
writing textbooks as well so this is one
part and in terms of research being a
faculty is very different from being a
like postdoc because you have to run a
research lab you have to think about how
we can find research funding to support
the post office to support a PhD
students so you have to turn you have to
devote a lot of time writing research
grant proposals to try to get money and
then you have to work with your students
so when I started off of as a faculty I
don't have a lot of students just to
spend a significant proportion of the
time working alone like as if as a
postdoc but as I get more and more
student as
spend time working with the student so
that's a transition and I spend time
teaching the student how to do research
like giving my research ideas to them to
execute and helping them write research
papers and I think that's a difference
but as I see so many students graduate
from my team and including my research
assistants they go to the top
universities in the world having full
PhD scholarship and I feel very good so
Wow yeah yeah what an important
responsibility to take on professing and
running a research and running helping
teach other students and making them
really successful that's a great
responsibility to take on and then what
about the transition to Westlake right
this happened a year ago that happens
that years ago but that was the
initiative to move back to China started
more than a year ago because my family
decided to move so my move to China was
a community a personal reason and it
concerns about like the the choice of my
whole family including my wife my kid
and also about education of my kid and
also about like to be closer to parents
etc and when I started to look I
searched for different universities and
then Westlake came into my sight when I
like look for research or universities
and luckily when I contacted Westlake I
was invited for an interview like just
within a day right and then I came here
and I realized oh the atmosphere is
really exciting so I stopped looking
further and decided okay I will call ya
and after I signed the country I signed
a contract in 2017 actually but I
thought I need to finish my research
project in Singapore and I have to see
that most of my graduate students they
graduate so I took a transition period
and formally moved back in now 2018 yeah
yeah and now being here you guys have a
lot of people already like NLP is a very
hot subject so you guys have two
postdocs seven research assistants eight
PhD students six it's and visiting
research students you're like 20 to 30
people you said you were packed over the
summer with lots of people visiting so
what is everyone working on fundamental
NLP is this main overarching yes yes so
the goal of my research team I mean is
to push forward fundamental NLP
technologies and so most of the students
they work on fundamental NLP problems
such as parsing and also information
extraction problems so what is
information extraction it is in short
instance we extract structured
information from unstructured text so
for example you want to extract out what
entities are mentioned in a text what
are the relations between these entities
such as a person can work for an
organization an organization can be
located in a location etc and you want
to extract event for example like the
CEO of a company has changed and you
also want to extract sentiment from
texts such as the diss people are
positive about this company or this
people are complaining about that
product so this information are highly
useful for further applications such as
stock market prediction etc so the goal
of my research is mostly focused on how
can we fundamentally solve an LP problem
to make algorithms intelligent and
understand
human languages in generating human
languages across domains and this is
currently still an unsolved problems so
we're devoting a lot of research
attention to those problems okay so we
have within fundamental NLP a an ability
to parse language in general and okay so
there's a couple things I think maybe
want to let's start let's start off this
way and then after we let's start off
this way and then we'll see where we go
from here so a very classical example is
maybe text in terms of like maybe books
or articles or that type of stuff
sentences posts on to social platforms
all this type of stuff and so you would
want to then have within a book let's
say like Harry Potter you would want to
know ok well this you identify that this
Harry Potter is a character first in the
book yeah you have to know that they're
a noun first yeah there are named
entities for exact name entity yeah and
then you have to identify the other
named entities like how do you train a
parser to find named entities mm-hm and
how do you make a knowledge graph graph
how the named entities have
relationships with each other and also
like their sentiment like if they're
happy or sad or if they're located in a
specific area how do you start doing
that yeah so you're given one example
which is like the analysis of novels so
this is something we're very interested
in and this is a I should call a very
fundamental research problem because it
doesn't have an immediate downstream
application so we work on these sort of
things for many many years
novels are
relatively low resource domain in a
sense that there are not a lot of human
labels in this domain so to correctly
extract named entities and relations
from novels is a domain adaptation
problem or a few short learning problem
because you don't have training examples
what we could do is we could train a
model from the news domain where there
are human annotations on entities and
their relations and we try to adapt that
kind of machine learning model to them
to a novel so this is called a domain
adaptation problem so we can use domain
adaptation technology to solve the
problem or alternatively a novel is a
relatively fixed world because the
character names they from the beginning
to the end they're relatively stable so
we can use statistical technology to
extract like what her so stable e
occurring across the whole novel and we
can sort of get an idea which are likely
personal names etc so that's completely
unsupervised that's another technology
what's more fundamental we're trying to
train algorithms that can learn and that
can generalize from a more a cognitive
point of view because we humans when we
humans learn we learn a few examples
from the text book and we can generalize
we are very good at summarizing the key
concepts and generalizing but so far the
machine learning algorithms they cannot
do it their data
hungry they must be trained and to end
so they basically they recite the
patterns from the training data and they
try to mechanically perform prediction
over new data so we try to do some more
cognitive driven approach to enable
machine learning algorithms to to be
more adaptive
more robust across different text
geometers yeah there are a lot of
research questions from this novel
analysis I love this one novel analysis
really interesting you were actually
teaching me about the this like kind of
like this bigger push for China internet
novels which I was very interesting most
people in the United States aren't so
familiar with that the United States is
very much so about like buying a
hardcopy book or or getting an audible
and audio copy of the book or even a
digital copy on the Kindle or whatever
yeah but this push for like internet
novels and China is really interesting
and how you guys can advance your NOP
parsers on the big internet corpus of
and people are like releasing chapters
and people are kind of like waking up
and like waiting for the specific
chapter to be released yeah that's
pretty cool
yeah so the like the Chinese novel
market is a little bit different I mean
including the music market so for
Chinese novel writers a lot of them go
to Internet the Internet publishers
they're not so so-called publishers
they're actually websites where you can
just upload your novels day by day
without getting paid and then all these
free internet novels are accessed by
readers across the country as well so
and how it works is that when a lot of
people pay attention to one over the
click the clicks will increase and the
website will pay the author by the
number of clicks in the end and this is
how the market runs in Chinese internet
novels and because of this there are a
lot of writers who maybe the publishers
won't even pay attention to because
their writing is so big to the and so
bad to the editor but they they're not
let's go online and they attract a
reader attention they improve their
writing so this kind of
the way it works is I think it's quite
unique in China and recently the Chinese
internet enormous has caught attention
from abroad as well so for example in
South Southeast Asia and in North
America people started to pick up like
the Chinese internet novels which talks
about maybe artificial world such as the
fairy world or the world of China China
martial art or the world of business the
world of military people like imagine a
lot of new worlds from there so so that
people wake up and wait for the new
release of the next episode etc so
luckily we recently got in collaboration
with some like a startup company who try
to do machine translation of Chinese
novels to English and so our upstream
work on the novel
analysis now got funded into some like
more systematic research yeah I like how
you're teaching me about this that
sometimes research is actually really
cool because you do research for the
sake of research and not necessarily for
the sake of getting some sort of a
reward from the market okay and then
what's cool is that
that you can end up getting a really
great partnership down the line once so
maybe some of the market catches up to
where your research is at yeah and then
they'll be like okay hey like we're
finally ready to use some of this great
research that you've done can we pay you
know can we collaborate can we work
together on this
yeah that's great yeah I have another
story which is about my work on like
stock market prediction and that started
off in 2013 when I was when I just
became an assistant professor so I
invited so so basically that line of
research caught a lot of attention
recently because more and more people
started to think about applying cutting
the air cutting-edge NLP technologies to
stock market prediction but when I
started working on that
people in the financial research
literature were still very crude on how
to use NLP technology so basically a lot
of their papers were about counting
words you just count the number of
negative words and you make market
predictions but because we could parse a
sentence into structures we can get
structured events from news so we could
predict the market better but what drove
me to work on that there are a lot of
factors one of the factors worse
interesting I can tell you a story I
invited a colleague from Spain to give a
talk in Singapore and he talked about
parsing and after his excellent talk one
of my colleagues stew stood up and asked
a question what is this useful for that
because this is really upstream so I was
a little bit embarrassed I thought okay
I don't know my invited speaker how can
he answer the question but he was really
calm saying look this could be used for
stock prediction because you can know
the events etc etc and then so that was
part of the things why don't we just
start off doing it and we started off
doing some research on that but we did
when we did that we were basically
trying to find a very interesting
application to parse him but we didn't
think about whether it can make a lot of
money or not yeah yeah yeah yeah so is
then a decent amount of what's happening
with stock market prediction based on
sentiment and now I saw yes there are a
lot of people working on that yeah
interesting yeah but we were also very
interested in like the news right
because the news talks about event and
events are happening around us every day
so what are the correlations between the
event and the market is a very
fundamental question yeah yeah
yeah like if there's a certain amount of
an issue happening with like a crop in a
region yeah and then that news can be
directly fat quickly parsed and then and
then given to people that are trading
that commodity exactly exactly that
exactly so so when I collaborated a more
and more with like trade or some people
in that field I realized that
information the unsymmetric between the
buyers and the sellers in the in the in
a in a capital market is a very big
issue actually especially in developing
financial markets such as China like
information are not not quickly conveyed
between different parties different
players in the field so in this aspect
natural language processing can
facilitate can like can in facilitate
the development of the capital market in
in this this developing markets and then
let's get to other examples we have this
great example of of parsing novels and
you can parse also like social media for
sentiment as well and for news we were
just talking about you can parse reports
and all different other kind of like
articles etc okay then there's this
whole other beast which is audio mmm-hmm
audios is in a sense like you know
you're not what one where you're using
like optical character recognition for
text number when it's text written
attacks like okay that's the word water
this is the word plant like you can tell
those are different uniquely different
but like water and how that you know
comes out into an actual wave that is
then processed and you have to do like
you have to do like a digital signal
processing every single time of what
that is
plant mm-hmm so how are you guys
involved in audio not really
we were based on we work on text but
like audio is very relevant to a natural
language processing so there's a field
called a speech recognition and there's
a field called text-to-speech
I guess those fields are necessary
before you can do natural language
understanding of all of you and over the
years deep learning has allowed those
field to develop also very quickly
for example text-to-speech technology
has developed a lot and the people can
mimic real people voice to the extent
that it can people can hardly
distinguish whether this is synthesized
on audio or this is on the human audio
yet the issues of the deep fakes yeah
yeah yeah interesting that you guys are
not as focused on that this is one of
the tough things about actually being a
principal investigator is that you have
to figure out where to invest your life
energy and your resources your time the
inspiring the other researchers you know
the more you work on the you know like
in the field the more you feel really
the energy at the time of a person of a
researcher is really really limited and
as long as you can bring breakthrough in
a small small field that's already a
quite big achievement right so I
remember a lot of scientists also talk
to me about it say that the energy of a
person the lifespan of a person is
really limited and develop it devote to
one small thing yeah yeah
so then let's do a dive into what
exactly it looks like to be building out
like a a catalog or a corpus of of your
NLP technologies and what that is like
you know in comparison to some of the
other big giants like you know Baidu and
Google and all these companies have also
their own NLP they have their own
fundamental and they'll be there working
on like yeah they have to work on like
these KPIs key performance indicators
and like all they have to like do
sometimes do things that are gonna make
money and get rewarded by the market and
focus on that but sometimes they can
also do research and so what
differentiates what you care about
versus what the other big corporations
are doing the fundamental I know yeah
yeah I think now the differentiation can
be rather small because as you mentioned
a lot of companies that give freedom to
their researchers are exploring whatever
they like but I feel that in the
academia we get more freedom in
exploring what's interesting for example
novel analysis it might not directly
apply to bind or Google but like we
could just spend a lot of time working
on it so so this this could be one
difference and in here we also got a
chance to collaborate with like a
neuroscientist for example there are
people working on like fly the fruit fly
brains they're people working on my
sprains there were also people working
on like human brains they we got a like
a colleague working on like bring
computer interfaces talking to those
people provide us a lot of chances to to
study like natural language under
standing from a cognitive point of view
which i think is also a unique thing
about academic research mmm yes you guys
have that multidisciplinary community
here where you can work with like
Mohammad so on yeah yeah soon and you
guys can he has exactly yeah yeah those
are exactly the people I talked to yeah
yeah we loved them as well those are
some of our favorites yeah he is
definitely an expert in visualizing all
the neurons and all the connections and
then the fruit fly brain yeah yeah yeah
actually the work has a lot to do with
the neural mechanisms of social
cognition and so in many ways I know
piece about social cognition and so it's
very interesting that you know one
writer can write a chapter and then it
can be viewed by millions of people
exactly exactly the more I work on this
the field to deeper I can understand the
field because the first time you work on
syntax for example you see syntax as
abstract trees but the more you work on
it you realize okay syntax it's not
detached from semantics sometimes you
understand the meaning before you
understand the structure interesting and
the more you work on it you more and you
realize no syntax it's not the chat from
cognition as well sometimes you really
need common sense or you need external
knowledge or world knowledge in order to
understand the syntax so Wow the more
you work on it the more you feel okay so
this is everything is coordinated and
it's coordinated from the fundamental
understanding teachers about how we have
like a relatable example with when I can
understand the meaning before I can
understand the syntax all right so let
me give an example on co-reference
tsoukalos means in a sentence you have a
lot of different pronouns and nouns
mentioning talking about the same
real-world entity but you don't know
which are connected with each other so
have an example say the dog cannot cross
the street because it was - and I can
have another world I can have
not a word in to finish the sentence
right and here there's one entity that
dog there's one entity the street
there's one like pronoun it and when I
say the last word is timid then it
refers to the dog right but when I say
the last word is wide or busy busy it
refers to the road and if I say the last
word is dark then it refers to the
environment right which even then was
there was no the environment was a very
abstracted even have its own word
exactly then it's implicit alright
mentioned whoa yeah so so you see and
when you try to resolve the core
efference or you try to resolve the
anaphora you have to really understand
the meaning or you could you should also
have a world knowledge about the
scenario of crossing the road whoa see
how would you ever teach fundamental NLP
to have implicit understanding that this
is happening in an environment yes so
this is part of the things who are
currently working on we're trying to
like a evaluate how how the current
models are equipped with common-sense
knowledge and how to impart common-sense
knowledge into NLP models so that's one
of the directions our team members are
working on how the heck do you impart
common-sense knowledge I think there are
there are a lot of different
technologies for example you can
directly apply explicit knowledge graph
to a natural language understanding
system or you can train a system over a
large amount of uh nanotech unlabeled
text and help to guide it like collect
common-sense knowledge from those texts
just as we collect common-sense
knowledge from text books but another
interesting thing is to connect
knowledge was cognition because as you
mentioned some researchers are working
on how we perceive the world so we have
an inbuilt ability to understand the
three-dimensional space and time so this
is what existing and help you systems
are not quite focused on this was a
really good interview with Gary Marcus
we just did on rebooting AI that you can
start building computers that can
perceive with space time and causality
and what would it be like if an NLP
system found itself in a space time and
causality yes yes existence yes they
must exist in a cognition system and it
must have a presentation in speech for
example I say this person is really big
where we're using space ideas to convey
an abstract concept and this is
prevalent in languages whoa yeah so
language perception is quite correlated
with our space and time perception and
causality is another thing in natural
language understanding so there's a task
and information extraction called
causality extraction yeah
and it also plays an important role used
examples causality abstraction a one
example is for example one famous CEO
steps down a company and the stock price
falls down so the text might not
explicitly mention that there's a call
correlation cause that the causality
correlation but you want to extract this
fact in order to help you better trade
in the market yeah
what do these these trees look like like
do you like how many different MLP
systems do you have that you can just
like do you just pick an NLP system for
a specific problem that you want to
solve and then you deploy that one do
these all kind of work together and
they're deployed at the specific need
that they that you that you need and
what do they're like trees of like
programming data that like their
algorithms what do those trees look like
that's a very good question I appreciate
your line of thought er so currently
every NLP task is solved alone so it's
like you have some training data you can
train an algorithm to learn from the
data and the algorithm can form this
task and it's called an to end learning
in putting out put out right so like
five years ago I was a advocator for
end-to-end learning as well because I
think this is really great it saves us
from feature engineering it saves us
from a lot of effort to develop how to
solve a particular task we just care
about the input and output and the deep
learning algorithm can remember okay the
correlation can discover the correlation
but now you think think about it every
tasks every task require a set of label
data to train on right and there are
tens and hundreds of tasks that a person
can need so this is definitely not the
ultimate way and I do an LP system shoe
should work right so I think about human
cognition again we learn syntax and we
learn spelling and we learn semantics
and in the end every knowledge came into
our system and we can perform even
better tasks by synthesizing all these
existing tasks together
and I'm personally very interested in
joint modeling as well so from the very
beginning I do research I work on for
example trying to work segmentation and
part of speech tagging because I believe
knowledge from these two tasks can be
mutually beneficial and can help a model
to better perform both tasks and now I
still hold this point of view but from a
deeper understanding so I believe that
if people can do natural language
understanding and all the related tasks
from a more cognitive driven way and
maybe one model killer all these tasks
yes
and now end-to-end systems cannot do it
because information from one task may
become noise for another Tempest yes if
we can mimic human understanding we can
automatically figure out which sources
of information are correlated and which
sources for information are conflicting
with each other so that's a that will be
that will make the algorithm truly
intelligent like right now I'm not
really using my my like somatosensory
system or my olfactory systems I'm not
really using my touch and my smell that
much right now I'm really just using
visual and I'm using language centers
right now and that if when you have your
NLP system that's able to have
everything that you've ever made
potentially embedded within it and then
once you feed it an input it recognizes
immediately out of let's say 47
different systems that it only needs to
use two of the 47 it shuts down the 45
so that you don't use any compute on
those and then you only use those two on
that problem and then you output out the
approximate approximately exactly
exactly
and in addition you can borrow whatever
can be borrow from the other senses to
better
conveying what you can convey in these
two senses for example you can say well
the task is so beautiful when you
describe a task right you're using your
visual senses to describe something that
is elegantly laid out and so basically
we can better integrate like knowledge
from different senses making them rather
than noise making them like boost the
performance of each other yes yes oh I
like that a lot
okay so what would you say is the most
popular NLP algorithm that you guys have
developed there are quite a few because
the underlying algorithm of sad par
which is a transition based model guided
by learning is adopted by a lot of
research our attempt to use cutting-edge
NLP technology on trading is also
receiving increasing research attention
another thing that we recently develop
is a recurrent neural network structure
to represent a graph so basically a lot
of things in languages are graphs for
example trees trees like syntactic trees
or core efference links they make a
graph out of this text structure and how
do you represent the graph is very
important to how you can utilize make
use of the knowledge from this text so
over the past two years or so we develop
some graph representation algorithms
called graph neural net graph recurrent
neural networks which has attracted
research attention as well so all in all
I believe that all these efforts
tu-tu-tu-tu-tu robust natural language
understanding
are are appreciated by some other
researchers in the community and we are
working together to evolve the field you
know and for people that are maybe
wanting to see if they can input in some
sort of of their own English text or
their own Chinese text and see what what
syntax and what semantics that you guys
pull from that and then gain some sort
of an understanding of how like the
knowledge tree may actually be created
from you though and like what what would
that look like would it look like me
entering in like a chapter or maybe
maybe some of the notes that I've
written on on a specific topic and then
and then what D what did what would what
would immediately happen at that point
would you literally just start you know
scanning from like top left to right
line by line you'd start scanning yes
start organizing yeah like take us
through that all right so my algorithm
will do the left or right scanning so
but not all the algorithms in the market
does that for example opposite to
transition based algorithms there are
graph based algorithm which will just
read the whole text or whatever you
enter as a chunk and start analyzing the
chunk like as a whole but my algorithm
will just read it from left to right and
incrementally start to build the
structure okay yeah it's using a lot of
state transition actions such as shift
and reduce so I believe that this kind
of understanding is closer to a psycho
linguistic processing
standing yeah okay so then you know the
first let's say let's say the first
character is as UA and then let's say
that we label you a with a variable an a
or the name right where I name a is yeah
you a and then the next name is Allen it
appears somewhere down line then you
Nabal you labeled that as B as like a
name B and then you maybe have a counter
on the amount of times that that name
has appeared you maybe start showing a
relationship between those names how
often they maybe appear in the book sort
of yes some sort of things like this
like this and the the latest algorithm
we develop contains one understanding
element and also one look-ahead element
that can try to project for example
you've read you and Ellen and probably
you're expecting a verb or something
yeah so so so we also have this look
ahead man you know look ahead yeah I
guess that's also it's really related to
neuroscience like into like humans are
always future prediction I think so I
think so that's that's inspired by human
language processing I think as soon as I
I say a few words
you would have an expectation what I was
saying there next yeah yeah yeah
where else do you see you and your team
mimicking doing some of the biomimicry
for computing computer systems we are
trying to go further in the line of
transition based processing we are
trying to avoid and to end systems we're
trying to like mimic how the human brain
works in understanding a language so
maybe this part is what we're working on
for example we're trying to find
structures in the neural system and
we're trying to make use of those
structures to better memorize to better
generalize etc so that's also why we use
graph neural network we work on graph
neural networks if you're starting to
immediately make a knowledge graph as I
enter in the English or the Chinese
writing yes in a sense that is a
knowledge graph that more connectionist
or rather than symbolic an association
Association associative memory yeah yeah
sort of you see you're starting to build
out an associative memory web as you
parse the words yes that's an attempt
because the thing about doing a research
is that you always try but you don't
know where you end up - but our goal is
to make some like cognition cognitive
driven NLP models that can really better
generate generalize that that that there
are more robust across different domains
that are more accurate than the current
systems are so so goal ultimately I can
read I really want to make and
understanding and natural language
generation systems that can help human
beings for example my personal assistant
can talk to me very freely so that it
saves my effort in human-computer
interfaces and automated driving cars as
well right machine translations stock
trading systems etc they can read over a
lot of news and reports in the market
and they can cleverly trade and also
novel reading algorithms for example I
can ask it whatever is out there
I like this novel a lot can you find me
a novel that's really similar to this
novel or the novel reading system will
read a lot of things and tell me
whatever I need that can also boost
literature research computational
literature study as well so if
algorithms can intelligently understand
languages then it can help us do a lot
of things this
making an computer system that is able
to do natural language processing that
mimics the way that we make associative
webs is really interesting that if I
could have one that's you know there is
in a sense a little like Alan Avatar
right now that exists in Google server
and like you know as soon as I go to you
know that google.com or by goo calm as
soon as you go there it like wakes up
and it's like ah what are they about to
write research for yeah you don't have
to search actually you only need to ask
questions as soon as you make a query
yes once you start and Entering yeah
yeah you don't have to enter keywords
anymore it is you can just talk to a
search engine hey I have this question
yeah yeah exactly just all all by voice
and then you know I thought by thought
is the next Edgeworth synthesized every
piece of information can get and give
you an answer that's tailored to your
need to your exact meet to your entire
life history that it's been analyzing
and it knows you
do you ever worry about the amount of
information that 10 cent or Baidu or
Alibaba or Amazon or Apple or Facebook
or blah blah blah that they have on you
were talking about asymmetry earlier do
you ever like worry about the asymmetry
that we don't know ourselves as well as
this little like avatar of you a in the
cloud knows who you are and yeah you've
looked at before yeah that's a profound
question so if you take one step further
you can think about what AI will do to
us right especially when you talk about
reinforcement learning so they can
explore and learn and in order to
achieve their goal that has four
different ways to do things and maybe
ultimately AI when obtaining every bit
of information about human beings they
might think about a goal like what are
the correlation between a and human
beings so that's a more profound
question and I think that's also related
to a question you asked in a very
beginning is technology the way we
should go right so in the end are we
seeking our own doom based on technology
are are we making our lives really
better based on technology so that's a
very profound question what are your
thoughts about that
so I certify I in this point about this
particular question I think it's good
and bad so good because well it seems
that we don't have a choice right now we
have to move on because this is already
we're so entrenched in this we cannot
move back anymore so everyone is
educated to be more technological to
survive in the society so we're moving
aligner we are making a lot of
excitement in technology development but
this contradicts with my philosophy
which is we know so little about the
world and
we shouldn't advance so much in in
knowledge maybe in uh in in making our
life more complicated we should make our
life simpler so this is my philosophy
it's also related to doubt you know Dow
of course yes I I believe that it makes
a lot of sense I read like loud
Eirene Dow and I think a lot of things
that he says makes sense
yo yeah yeah so you remember in the very
do you think technology is part of the
way no not at all
whoa the way is against technology you
remember in Dow he claims that you
should try not to be too clever being
too clever is not a good thing and why
in the very beginning he says Dow or the
rules in the truth or the wisdom is not
terrible why is it not terrible because
what can be told is our whole cognition
system and the reality the truth is
beyond our cognition system and I used
to talk to mathematicians and I learned
that one axiom in math is an equivalence
axiom so which says if one is equivalent
to one and one is not equivalent to zero
because I talk in binary terms because
I'm a computer scientist so in Laos in
Laos
he says one is you're half zero is
nothing one is something zero is nothing
and he says the truth cannot be told and
because one can be 0 so this completely
contradicts our mathematical system so
the what he claims is that the real
truth is not X
layna more by math and maybe maybe this
is sort of coincides with contemn MEC
annex because in our math system a
cannot be equivalent to B cannot be that
at the same time equal to B and unequal
to B but in quantum mechanics particles
can be at the same time here and there
and two particles can be separated like
a very very far from each other but they
can be tied with each other so these
kind of things are not directly
explainable by the like the commission
system and also tend to believe that as
I mentioned to you a bit earlier a math
the whole math system is a simple
rediscovery of our cognitive system it's
because we live in this
three-dimensional space and time so we
are we are we are we evolved the human
the human beings we evolved over a
lalalala long years to get like adapted
to this system to survive in this system
so we rediscover algebra we rediscover
like a geometry like all these kind of
things which make sense to us and we
create the math system as a summary of
our reflection of our own cognitive
system but as loud point out that now is
beyond this system so one can be zero
they can be the same thing and so that's
why he he he claims that we should do as
little as possible which is the opposite
to what we are facing right now we try
to do as much as possible the loudest
sense we should do as little as possible
and for me I want to travel around the
world to know the world to know more but
Lao Tzu said the more you travel the
you know so the real knowledge you can
sit in the sofa close your eyes and be
quiet and quiet down and meditate quiet
down and at the stage your thoughts
become zero
it became infinity and you meet
immediately and know everything around
you I remember like you also interviewed
a professor tree like waiter and also
said in Buddhism they also do this you
meditate and you begin to know things
beyond your three dimensional space yeah
right so this kind of practice is is um
what people who practice Taoism they
chase after and I mean I think it makes
a lot of sense but I'm very far from
that kind of wisdom because I'm also
very excited in working on what I'm
working on
likewise yeah so then maybe there is
some sort of a way to both combine one's
ability to dive deep into that zero but
also to enjoy the beautiful planets
called cultures and treasures and
technologies and I'm not sure the state
if ities and meanings and yes all these
things all these things when you feel
that this is exciting when you feel that
this is elegant this is far from chaos
but loud says chaos is something oh he
says one paragraph says are Dow when tau
becomes things right
and now men are things it makes things
by making chaos out of chaos you start
to have shape and out of chaos you start
to make and this very much coincides
with quantum mechanics because when you
go to the particle no shape is there
right is
okay I'll take one of my friends
reference this as crickets trying to
understand human civilization and we are
in a sense the crickets trying to
understand the way that way and if the
way is chaos it also coincides with the
entropy law but do you think it's an
impossible that we understand the way I
don't think anything's impossible I
think it's definitely possible because I
know people who know more than us like
the normal people because you know those
people who practice Dow yeah they try to
be recluse that yeah get away from the
world yes and they try to hide
themselves and some of them like also
reveal something right so so so there I
definitely know there are people who
can't know more than I can know I know
that there are people who can do more
than I can do so this kind of things
exist but I don't think you can at the
same time be very conscious and at the
same time be very chaotic as I said I
have another story maybe I want to share
with you which is the entropy law Radio
universe if you have a system the system
will obey the entropy locus as the time
goes the time what is time I don't know
but according to some like a physicist
the time is is just a one coordinate but
the thing the uniqueness about the time
is that the time flows by obeying the
entropy law everything will become more
and more chaotic from simplicity it
evolves complexity from from know from
from order and from order to under the
orders from this order to any sort in a
sense that could be what simplicity to
complexity this may be may be I mean if
you assume that the universe is a
then the universe will go to chaos in
the end then what about intelligence
intelligence is definitely structured it
is it's not chaos that's four so I think
intelligence is only something something
like an anomaly anomaly in the
development of whole universe it's like
the the University of the universe is a
river there can be some swirls in the
river and we're just heading a little
bit could it be a purposeful anomaly so
that Oh
so that order evolves disorder
simplicity involves complexity which is
then gives a human brain and a human
civilization at some point which then
becomes sophisticated enough to
understand the initial source code of
the simplicity that it came from and
then do a full circle and make the
simplicity and start the next cycle
again so there is no linear time but
it's a cyclical time and we're just
embedded in the middle I think that's
possible but I don't like it's a fun one
but I don't know because anything is a
possibility to those people who do not
know right so I don't know yeah but I I
sort of I I tend to think it makes sense
that everything will go back to the
original point and like through the
cyclic thing I think it makes a lot of
sense to me and when you really tap more
and more deeply into that feeling the
the the at times the political economic
social machinery around us kind of just
fades just yeah exactly or more yeah
exactly able to be with exactly I'll if
you're really into a philosophy then
especially if you're really into the
philosophy of Taoism then nothing is
important right yeah that's what that's
that's what the ultimate truth
where are the ultimate truth do you keep
building better and Opie haha just like
I can't I can't help I can't help
thinking about the philosophy means I
can't help like working on what I work
on yet doing and not doing how to figure
out when to do when to not do yeah it's
a it's a very difficult question I think
it's a dynamic right it is yeah every
time it's a bifurcation of your life
trajectory yeah do I do four hours of an
Opie work right now do I not do do I do
play with my child do I do a hike out to
wet the actual Westlake
yeah or you just sit in a room and
meditate yeah yeah
it's one of the hardest philosophical
hardest hardest question yeah yeah
being someone that really understands
parson here we are in this reality how
do you parse the reality for the most
essential things I don't quite get your
question so how do you do me how do I
understand the reality how do you
identify the essentials how do you parse
for the essentials of reality like we
like this idea of the way it's such an
essential right right what's the
essential so it depends on what you call
reality I think both the Taoism and
endow practicers and some of the monks
they say whatever you can see and
whatever you can hear is not real right
so those that you cannot see those who
cannot hear in your senses are real so I
remember one of my friends who is also a
professor he mentioned to me what he
reads from those books so when people
the monks when they record like whatever
they hear they say oh this is a plant
but in reality it's not a plant but I
named it a plant in order to be able to
communicate with you so I think those
people they really I think they have
better understanding of the reality but
the reality cannot be told as loud
success because our cognitive system and
our communication system are based on
like one is one zero is zero so if I'm
already assigning a symbol like a word
plant to that yeah it's not actually bad
it's not actually humans just use that
word in English Chinese Arabic can be
whatever language yeah to describe that
so when I asked you hey will you move
that plant yeah
or will you water that plant yeah that
that's how you you know and you know
what I want would like you to do but so
as soon as we start doing that words and
symbols that those are artificial
additions to this way and they're
actually in a sense further maybe
complicating yeah the way and the way is
actually in action yeah what would be an
ideal NLP tool mm-hmm maybe 20 or 30
years down the line like give it a good
amount of decades down the line what
would be this ideal NLP tool that could
be the absolute best cutting-edge thing
that could solve all of the cool
visionary things that you want to see
happen well I guess it's easy to answer
because a real NLP system is an NLP
system that can really understand what
you say and of course this is
challenging because sometimes what you
say requires a lot of background
knowledge but I'm assuming that if an
NLP system can really be equipped with
the cognitive system that humans are
equipped with at least it can understand
the basic science the basic humanity is
the basic background knowledge that
people have so that can it can help
people in their like communication and
maybe even do some more exciting things
such as the more analytical things
a 100% understanding yeah of what you
are saying and yeah
and helping be a really good catalyst
for what your goals are mm-hmm yeah yeah
do you think this is a simulation I
don't know I have another hypothesis of
the world so which is maybe it's a
simulation because our Jian structure
looks like a computer code right so only
a small fraction of the gene structure
is translated into protein in our body
there's still a large proportion which
is some uninterpretable to us so I don't
know whether we are a cold and
everything is a simulation nashwa what
do you think is the most beautiful thing
in the world most beautiful thing well I
love the nature I love nature and I love
humanities I think there are a lot of
beautiful things in the world which are
very much order for example when I if
you look at like art right there are so
many different cultures in a world and
each culture has its own unique art and
inspires you like makes you feel excited
appreciate the beauty and nature is also
very beautiful I like traveling a lot I
go to those ups I go to those like wild
places like in the mountains in the
cliffs and I appreciate the beauty of
the nature as well so so I believe that
the beauty is is appreciated by the
whole humanity and we have a common
sense of what's beautiful and maybe what
is structural is beautiful I don't know
yeah but it seems that it's so deeply
rooted in our cognitive system that we
are frigid disability
along the way thank you so much for
coming on to our show this has been such
a pleasure so thank you it's nice
talking to you thank you thank you thank
you thanks everyone for tuning in we
greatly appreciate it we'd love to hear
your thoughts in the comments below on
the episode let us know what you're
thinking have more conversations to your
friends families co-workers people
online about natural language processing
about fundamental NLP about parsing for
syntax parsing for semantics about
making more intelligent NLP algorithms
about the meaning of life about Taoism
about philosophy as well have more
conversations about all those things
check out the links in the bio below to
you a in the lab also reach out if you'd
like to get involved and collaborate and
also support the artists the
entrepreneurs leaders around the world
that you believe in support simulation
our links are below so we can continue
doing cool things like coming on site to
great places like Westlake to interview
such brilliant minds here and go and
build the future everyone manifest your
dreams into the world we love you very
much thank you for tuning in and we will
see you soon all right okay yes good job
brother thank you good job
[Music]